we have a document
that i quote from in war at home an fbi
document from the late 60s in which they
actually say outright
since the purpose of cointelpro
is to disrupt
it is immaterial whether facts exist to
substantiate the charge they say it
straight out and on this basis as you
were saying frank they had activists
arrested on false charges put in jail
forced to trial and in some very
important cases
um
convicted and still in prison today we
have the testimony before the senate
intelligence committee of one um
infiltrator so-called of the clean for
the fbi who on the fbi payroll a man
named gary thomas rowe what did he do on
the fbi payroll
he beat up freedom riders in alabama
they knew he was going to he did it he
reported doing it they kept paying him
then he was part of the group that
planted the bomb in the church in
birmingham where the four little black
girls were killed
and they they still keep paying him and
then in 1965 he's a shooter one of the
people shooting from the clan car when
the northern civil rights worker viola
luizo is assassinated by the klan in
1965 the man still stays on the payroll
the city of birmingham
filed a formal report with the senate
judiciary committee demanding a federal
inquiry into the now systematic
harassment
throughout particularly south carolina
georgia and alabama of locally elected
black officials
who are being
set up in elaborate stings
indicted brought before grand juries or
even when the stings totally fail as in
the case for instance of birmingham's
mayor arrington smeared in the
newspapers with full stories leaked by
the fbi and this is being coordinated
out of washington by an organized crime
strike force of the u.s attorney's
office working with the fbi
around the country and then we have the
environmental
the attacks on our civil liberties by
the fbi and other government agencies
from the past and the present
with an author of a book on the subject
right now
on alternative
views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brian glick is a public interest lawyer
who's had a long history in struggles
for civil rights and for helping various
people who've been stepped on by the
establishment he's an organizer and
lawyer for civil rights welfare prison
at apartheid movements
he also is chief counsel for three
ex-black panthers seeking to overturn
wrong convictions
he's taught at some universities but the
main thing we want to talk with him
right now is an incredible book
incredible book the war at home
the war at home covert action against
u.s activists and what we can do about
it now it's just a small it's a short
book only about 75 pages but it is just
packed with outrageous accounts of
outrageous activity by the establishment
police organizations to try to destroy
any type of descent in this country but
it also gives you in some instructions
on what to do and how to fight back
but before we have our interview here
are some new stories from the
alternative press
spotlight
had a
had an article by sherman skolnick of
chicago he and his investigative team
have really looked closely into the
origins of the iran-iraq war
and they come up with an angle which
says what they really the bankers and
all and the oil companies particularly
wanted was to zap
kuwait
not iraq they just used iraq as an
excuse
and here's what they had to say
the kuwaiti petroleum corporation
had some of the largest reserves in the
world
and had come
been able to get in a position to
compete with exxon
of course that's the
main rockefeller oil company used to be
standard
well the kuwaiti company
bought the gulf oil chain of gas
stations in southern united states and
they also bought a bunch of refineries
now the big oil companies have hadn't
minded that much in the past when the
gulf states the arabs just
were in control of taking the oil out of
the ground but they didn't want them to
be getting into the area of refining or
in merchandising and selling at the pump
here is where the major oil companies
would still be able to control those
arabs
well they also started
not only
selling in the united states but also in
europe
and the rockefellers tried to stop them
from spreading
this marketing
and refining by getting uh hatching up
some problems with some of the federal
regulatory agencies in the united states
and trying to stick the law on them in a
way one way or another
but this didn't work out now there was
another problem with kuwait
they had so much money they had 200
billion dollars in investments in the
united states
they were the largest stockholders and
some very
sizable companies and even some
rockefeller organizations like
commonwealth edison they even gotten
into the broadcast field
one of the things that was done
to control the price of
petroleum and keep it high
this this effort was on the decline
because kuwait was keeping the price too
low according to what the oil companies
the
british petroleum and the rockefellers
wanted
so they started supporting iraq
and at the meantime we're telling kuwait
to uh
well don't pay attention to these
demands that iraq has on you like the
ramallah oil fields the iraqis were
sucking oil out of an iraqi oil field
and also they were keeping the prices
low much lower than what
the
people wanted in the banks and so as a
result they were afraid of all these
various things this economic power that
kuwait was gaining
and
so
kuwait according to this apparently was
the main
reason for this gulf war and not really
iraq
for much of the war with iraq the
american public was treated to daily
footage of the united states precision
guided missiles
and iraqi stud missiles were constantly
referred to as weapons of terror largely
because of their inaccuracy
all of this gave the impression that the
united states war machine was running a
very clean war with civilians and
civilian areas being spared
while military targets were being
destroyed with amazing high-tech
precision
but a story on march 17th in the austin
american statesman and also a story on
april 3rd in the guardian
paint an entirely different picture
both of these stories quote an air force
general general merrill mcpeak
as saying that although precision guided
missiles
were 90 percent accurate
these only accounted for 7
of the total u.s tonnage of destructive
force dropped on kuwait occupied kuwait
and iraq
where's the other 93 percent well
according to mcpeak these were not the
precision guided missiles these were
dumb missiles with 25 accuracy
uh and after some careful calculations
the austin american statesman the
guardian and i came up with the same
sobering statistics
that
70 percent of the united states
missiles
miss their target
in fact the information provided by
mcpeek and a senior pentagon official
indicate that of the 88
500 tons
of destructive force dropped on iraq and
occupied kuwait and estimated
62
137 tons missed their target
this picture contrasts sharply with the
high-tech never miss image of our
military industrial complex that the
pentagon very carefully
cultivated during the war it was a
picture put forth to ensure public
support
for its bombing of iraq
back to the stone age
you remember april glasby who was the
u.s ambassador to iraq
and supposedly
gave the green light
to saddam hussein to attack kuwait
the iraqis released the transcript of
the conversations with april gillaspie
and uh and she later denied this that
they said they were inaccuracies and you
can't trust that saddam saying he's a
liar
anyway but while the iraqi u.s war was
going on
april gillaspie was kept incommunicado
somewhere nobody
could find april glaspie and find out
and verify if in fact the u.s had given
the green light to saddam hussein
[Music]
well we saw her performance in congress
where the congress people were fawning
over her and not to really grilling her
on it and she was saying oh no saddam
hussein was a lion and all that however
the problem is according to william
sapphire
who was a columnist for the new york
times he said all this baloney all this
stuff by the state department and the
u.s
government is just a flat bald lie
that what glaswey was saying
the problem is that
glaspy wrote an internal memorandum of
what went on and sent it to washington
and she confirmed in this memo
what the iraqis later released
now she claims it
well that really isn't true
however assistant secretary john kelly
passed the word and said that the iraqi
transcript was essentially accurate
and he wrote a memo to that effect also
so what the administration is doing is
lying again during the war we kept
hearing about uh how good our
intelligence was that our satellites
were so uh precise and
so accurate that they could pick up a
glove that was on the desert
and yet somehow they didn't know what
the condition of saddam hussein's army
was
i mean they kept saying that it was it
was a huge threat and
that they had to you know we had to have
all this firepower there because uh he
had amassed these huge
seasoned armies
and yet
at the same time we know now that uh
that that wasn't the case at all
it's hard to tell what really went on
yet perhaps a leak out here and there
uh on one hand
um you could say well any fool can know
that
iraq after losing uh
anywhere from 500 000 to a million
people
being bled white
by that iran iraq war wouldn't be in all
that good shape
they might have the republican guards
but they had to draft all these people
who didn't want to be there for the main
part of their army particularly the ones
that would be absorbing the first blows
so
on the other hand there were all these
statistics about how they had all these
numbers of tanks all these numbers of
people and they were experts at mine
warfare
so what was really the case there were
some indications that there were
disagreements between the intelligence
people in washington and the
assessments of the intelligence
people there in the field who were much
more confident and it turned out they
were correct
so you don't know whether it's an
intelligence
deficiency
in the united states or whether
all this was just pumped up for
propaganda purposes so it looked like
hey we had a formidable foe over there
and we had to take care of him
in reality he just wasn't all that much
in these times did a story
in march
where they published satellite
photographs
that
contradicted what george bush said
right after
hussein invaded kuwait
on the third day
on august 5th last summer bush said that
hussein had 320 000 troops in kuwait and
they were massing along the saudi border
however
uh this article of in these times
published some photographs
that were taken from satellites and they
clearly showed the saudi border and they
clearly showed that there was nothing
there
oh
right there before your very eyes
so who knows what was going on
one gets the feeling
though that there was some manipulation
going on there
we'll have more news later in the
program but now let's have our interview
with brian glick author of the war at
home
about the attacks on our civil liberties
by government agencies especially the
fbi brian
frank this is a book which uh as i call
a an outrage a page you just stop at any
page and start reading and you think
gosh
some things that you would never think
that would happen in the good old usa
tell us about green world right yes well
some of it is very recent a lot of what
i deal with is what we learned about
what happened in the 60s because we have
more documentation of that
but
just in the 1980s and not too far from
from here in austin
we have the story of the fbi operations
against cespas the committee in
solidarity with the people of el
salvador and it turns out some more than
200 other
religious labor and community groups the
marinol sisters the
new jewish agenda the southern christian
leadership conference the united auto
workers united steel workers all were in
the list of targets for their opposition
to u.s policy in central america and the
some of this was in the newspapers and
on to network tv very briefly
back in i think the winter of 1988 but
the story was just about some
surveillance
a little bit about making files about
people some discussion of oh did webster
know when he was the director before he
moved on to the cia
and would anybody be punished but there
was no real discussion of what really
was going on
in this program and we know something
about that because the man who blew the
whistle on the program a man named frank
virelli who infiltrated sispis on the
payroll of the fbi in dallas texas right
here in dallas texas in the 1980s from
81 to 84 and operated countrywide
against sispes has talked and sworn
affidavits and testimony before congress
for congressional committees and in
court
and vareli tells a very important story
his assignment in infiltrating sispis
was not primarily to get information
about syspis as objectionable as that is
the assignment in the words of the fbi
higher-ups was quote unquote to break
to break sispes to destroy
the movement against u.s intervention in
central america and ferelli has talked
about some of the things that he and
other people in the fbi did to that end
they put out phony publications
bogus publications that they had written
circulated in the name of sispes in
order to alienate people who might
otherwise have become involved to
discredit sispes in the communities that
it worked in they broke into the homes
and offices and cars of sispes members
they hired right-wing students to
disrupt
rallies and other public events that
sispes was holding
verrilli testifies that he was told to
seduce a nun
who was a leader of the dallas texas
chapter of sispes
so that the fbi could obtain blackmail
photos
it was suggested that he planned guns on
sispes members
and he testifies that he and other
agents routinely exchanged information
about both u.s and central american
activists
with the salvadoran national guard which
means in fact that's with the death
squads exactly with the death squads in
that country and this is an example
from the 1980s
of covert action really the kind of
covert action for which the cia has
become rightly infamous
around the world but done here at home
against domestic distance dissidents
against uh people who dissent from
government policy in the united states
and there are many other examples
in war at home
of current operations of this kind
against
networks providing sanctuary for
refugees from el salvador and guatemala
against opponents of apartheid in the
united states against
local black groups against the puerto
rican independence movement
against various peace organizations even
since war at home was published even
more information has come out
all we now know from uh in 1990 in
february of 1990
the city of birmingham
filed a formal report with the senate
judiciary committee demanding a federal
inquiry into the now systematic
harassment
throughout particularly south carolina
georgia and alabama of locally elected
black officials
who are being
set up in elaborate stings
indicted brought before grand juries or
even when the stings totally fail as in
the case for instance of birmingham's
mayor arrington smeared in the
newspapers with false stories leaked by
the fbi and this is being coordinated
out of washington by an organized crime
strike force of the u.s attorney's
office working with the fbi around the
country and then we have the
environmental movement under attack we
have the national leadership of earth
first
facing federal criminal conspiracy
charges on the basis of what
the word of an fbi infiltrator into
earth first and now we have
leaders of earth first organizing
students in large numbers
for redwood summer based on the
mississippi freedom summer of the 60s to
go into northern california to block the
clear cutting of the forests there
and
to our organizers of that who are
leading pacifists within leading
advocates of non-violence within earth
first and who are doing very important
work in bringing workers for the logging
industries into this struggle to see
that clear cutting of the woods is
actually going to reduce employment and
that what the environmentalists are
proposing is actually what would save
jobs a bomb explodes in their car a few
days before this um program for the
summer is to start
and do the fbi and police try to figure
out
who planted it and what's the role of
the lumber companies who've been death
threatening these very people no
they pressed charges against the victims
of the bombing they put them in prison
and they say that they were carrying a
bomb these pacifists were carrying bombs
in their own car and it exploded on them
there's many instances of that from the
60s there's these kind of false bombing
charges of the priests daniel and philip
berrigan and some nuns a group of them
were um indicted by the fbi in a
supposed plot to bomb the capital
in 1960 um
9
21 leaders of the black panther party in
new york were jailed for two years on
the ludicrous charges that they were
planning to bomb department stores
during the
christmas shopping season when they were
most crowded and bombed the botanical
gardens two years they were held in
prison
one hour the jury acquitted every one of
them on every count it was a totally
false charges and there are many other
examples like that brian can you go back
and give us a little bit more history
this is something that's been going on
for a long time
and we know a lot no i mean back to the
start of the of the country as a matter
of fact at least but let's go back and
talk about cointelpro now i give some
lectures to university students i said
anybody know what cointelpro is not a
hand raising but this is a hair-raising
thing i mean you've been talking about
some awful things but back then
they were killing people assassinated
yes they were they were doing all kinds
of things of that sort and they still do
to one degree or another not as much
we'd have assassination stories though
if they were involved in planning this
bomb judy berry's in the critical list
in the hospital
cointelpro
is an acronym made up of the three
opening letters of the three words
counter intelligence
program
it's the name the really misnamed
because it wasn't countering any foreign
intelligence operations it was as even
the senate intelligence committee
recognized the so-called church
committee in its 1976 report covert
action what we've come to call domestic
covert action covert action against
domestic dissidents we know about
cointelpro not because the government
came clean
but because in april of in march rather
of 1971
a small group of activists still
unidentified formed themselves as a
committee to investigate the fbi and
they made their way into a little
suburban office of the fbi in a town
called media pennsylvania just outside
of philadelphia
they came away with some boxes of
documents and some of them which were
clearly political police operations had
that strange caption co-intel pro
and this was remember
soon after the pentagon papers had
showed how systematically the u s
government had lied to the people of
this country about its war against
vietnam and soon there were the
watergate scandals and the people in
charge of this country were worried
that confidence was being shaken in the
government and they needed to go through
a number of steps to restore confidence
so they had a real freedom of
information act briefly and they set up
the senate intelligence committee in the
house intelligence committee and
gradually far from the entire
documentary record we're talking here of
the documents that were internal
to the fbi from headquarters to the
field offices what you should do from
the field offices back what we propose
fbi modifies or approves then they
report on what happened then they adjust
the strategy of heavy flow of paper back
and forth one
of the documents initiating that program
is reproduced on the cover of war at
home a page from it and it says straight
out front the purpose of this new
counter-intelligence endeavor
is to quote disrupt
misdirect
discredit or otherwise neutralize but
they were trying to destroy
legal dissent people who were trying to
change absolutely and this is what they
they themselves recognized luther luther
king
was a major target of this a name target
of this program all through the 1960s
they tried to cut off his funds they
tried to discredit him
in 1964
as king was preparing to receive the
nobel peace prize
the fbi put together
an audio tape made up of a collage of
snippets from wiretapping and bugging of
kings hotel and motel rooms as he moved
around the country
and this tape gave the impression
possibly true quite possibly not that
king was having extramarital affairs as
he moved around
and then it reads right out of one of
these spy thrillers you know send a tape
down to florida get some unmarked paper
use gloves and they put a little cover
letter on it unsigned and they send this
tape to king and it says
king you're going to be exposed we're
going to show this tape to your family
they will leave you
we're going to release it publicly your
moral authority will be eroded
you have one way out
and that is to kill yourself
they were consciously trying to provoke
king's suicide
in 1964 and the story doesn't even stop
there because the documents show
that they had their own candidate
to replace king
in leadership of the black movement
after they had eliminated king if they
were to succeed
and that mean
a black man who was a corporate lawyer
in new york at the time with no
connection to the civil rights movement
later became a judge in new york and he
emerges in the 1980s
as none other than the infamous sam
pierce
ronald reagan secretary of housing
caught in some of the worst scandals
absolutely
absolutely this was the man that the fbi
was cultivating and promoting and trying
to put into leadership of the black
movement if they could only find a way
to get rid of king there were so many
ways in which they
le they illegally or legally railroaded
activists black activists and
native american activists into prison
for long terms
and with the collusion of judges this
was an amazing thing absolutely tell us
about how the judges would do that with
you
we have a document
that i quote from in war at home an fbi
document from the late 60s in which they
actually say outright
since the purpose of cointelpro
is to disrupt
it is immaterial where their facts exist
to substantiate the charge they say it
straight out and on this basis as you
were saying frank they had activists
arrested on false charges put in jail
forced to trial and in some very
important cases
um
convicted and still in prison today
there are several cases that of um
geronimo pratt for one and leonard
peltier the native american activist for
another pratt is a former black panther
leader which have even been recognized
by amnesty international and carried on
network television but they remain in
prison their case is rejected i worked
on pratt's case it's part of how i came
to learn what
ended up published in war at home
and
prant
was convicted in 1972 of a 1968 robbery
and murder on a tennis court in santa
monica
only
in the early 80s long after his
conviction and unsuccessful appeals when
we got hold of some portion of the
record of his fbi files did we find that
the main witness against him someone who
had been in the panthers and who
testified it was in fact on the payroll
of the los angeles police department and
the fbi right when he testified that he
denied it from the witness stand in fact
this was a strategy to destroy all of
the progressive movements of the time
the black panthers the brown berets the
native american movement the puerto
rican national independence movement
just today uh brian was on a panel at
the national lawyers guild in austin
with representatives of all these
movements who have continued to be
harassed for decades after the 60s and
through the 70s through these co-intel
type government harassment uh programs
right it continues it did the name
changes by the the targets the
techniques
agencies but the strategy continues and
the basic methods continue and
fbi documents admit this they said i
think in your book that they said well
we can't do cointelpro anymore but we'll
just change the name and then do
something more basically that's right
but it was so i mean we're talking about
heavy-duty uh central american
salvadoran stuff because as you note
uh in your book that the fbi and its
allies waged an all-out war on the
native american people okay they killed
69 residents of the pine ridge
reservation from 1973 through 76. fbi
the bureau of indian affairs and the um
police
officials of the um leadership placed by
the bureau of indian affairs
on that reservation all of them working
together killed that number of people
the fbi the document show was
orchestrating and coordinating it not
all the deaths were directly at fbi
hands so there were many and what's
really uh repelling about this is that
the fbi the court system the whole
judiciary is supposed to be above
politics and it's being used as a wing
of political repression of particularly
reactionary groups against progressive
movements so this is really what's going
on here is political repression of a
systematic way that is robbing people of
the right of dissent and struggling for
social change that's really what's going
on here absolutely in the name of
protecting democracy they're subverting
democracy can you tell me now it used to
be you know the pinkertons were
laying a heavy hand on the labor
movement
and then the fbi but now
there is a total structure
interconnected interrelated structure of
police repression private and public
around the country can you describe it
that's right see one one thing that
happened in the 1960s as bad as it was
was that the fbi under j edgar hoover
was
um not a team player they were they were
they wanted to protect their information
and protect their turf and there was a
lot of interagency
competition and a lot of competition
between different levels of government
what we've had since hoover's death it
is a gradual integration of all of this
we see it exemplified in the fact that
of course bush moves from the cia to the
white house and webster moves from the
fbi to the cia the cia and the fbi and
the various intelligence agencies of the
armed services
and
the federal emergency management
administration so-called the fema they
all work together on a federal level
then they work through these joint
anti-terrorist task forces and we should
note
that
especially with the erosion of the cold
war as anti-communism becomes less and
less effective
as a rhetorical kind of rationale and a
way of mobilizing people to support this
stuff
anti-terrorism has now
become the way of red-baiting now we
thought people are terrorist-based when
they were respected
exactly exactly
right but here we have
the fbi and the cia
and the drug enforcement administration
and the immigration immigration service
they're integrated and have computer
relationships
with local
red squads they don't call them red
squads anymore they call them
anti-terrorist units well
state police organizations but also with
corporations and with the law
enforcement uh
intelligence unit which is a private
organization
that is not subject to the freedom of
information act can you tell us how this
system works well there's a lot of
different private groups or so-called
private groups that um are made up of
various right wings and the fbi always
cooperated in different ways with
right-wing groups and i go through it
more i forgot about the relationship
with the nazis the clan an ex-minister
group known as the secret army
organization in southern california all
of which are mounted to a kind of covert
aid to these right-wing groups in the
guise of moving against them
we have the testimony before the senate
intelligence committee of one
infiltrator so-called of the kleen for
the fbi who on the fbi payroll a man
named gary thomas rowe what did he do on
the fbi payroll
he beat up freedom riders in alabama
they knew he was going to he did it he
reported doing it they kept paying him
then he was part of the group that
planted the bomb in the church in
birmingham where the four little black
girls were killed
and they they still keep paying him and
then in 1965 he's a shooter one of the
people shooting from the clan car when
the northern civil rights worker viola
luizo is assassinated by the klan in
1965 the man still stays on the payroll
what what's been found is that when you
look at the documentary record of their
supposed cointelpro operations against
the right-wing groups there's very
little harassment virtually no
disruption
massive paid infiltration
up to 40 of the members of the klan by
the late 60s were receiving fbi stipends
so this is a form of helping them so
long as they targeted the same groups
which they did mostly if the clan win
orion went after some jewish or catholic
local business or political leader they
might you know
slap him on the wrist a little bit but
almost always the targets were common
and as long as the targets were coming
they would work together today there's a
bigger proliferation of um right-wing
research groups and investigative
agencies and this kind of thing and that
many of the break-ins that have been
experienced by central america groups in
the 1980s and there have been hundreds
reported to the center for
constitutional rights and probably
hundreds more that have happened
conspicuous break-ins they do
we learned from the 60s record also
surreptitious break-ins where they get
information
that you don't even know they've done
until later you find out maybe from some
agent who disaffects or from some
records but they also do conspicuous
break-ins when they know how to be
surreptitious and those are designed to
intimidate to terrorize as well as to
destroy records
and information and fi research files
and so forth so
it's hard to tell exactly how this is
working these days private groups get
tips from the law enforcement about who
to go after then they share the
information with them
but the f the fbi or police didn't do it
directly you can't get freedom of
information against the private groups
you really can't get it too much against
the public agencies anymore the freedom
of information act while it's still
worth using has been very very limited
and undermined in the 80s so you
very frequently get these documents
which i've seen over and over again
where all you see is your name at the
top and the or and but then when and
that's it
everything else white it out
what is the response of the public
against this whole network of public and
private state repression against
activists and those dissenting against
official policy what can we do to fight
back well i discuss in war at home two
levels of fighting back which are
complementary and and really depend on
each other and one is public activity to
expose what's still going on what we're
doing
right exactly because a lot of people
think it ended with bad j edgar hoover
right it didn't start with him and it
sure as hell did not end with him um
and then the other is since we're not we
don't have the power in this time in
history to really stop all of this we
can limit it by our public activity and
that's important we also need to be
discussing among activists and
inactivist organizations and people's
movements how to cope with some of the
things that they do so for instance i
have a page in the book um
dealing with a problem of so-called
investigative interviews in which the
fbi knocks on people's doors to harass
them and goes to landlords and employers
and friends and so forth and that page
that box is entitled if the fbi drops by
just say no
and there's other advice a lot of
different kinds of advice about um and
that advice simply sums up what i've
learned and what other people have
learned i'm going around the country and
meeting and talking with groups
campus groups community activists and so
forth and and hoping to engender a
discussion or in fact engendering a
discussion which will lead to a much
richer collection of of how to deal with
all of this among ourselves how to deal
with
um people who seem to be infiltrators
but we don't really know and the
importance of not loosely pointing the
finger at people because the fbi are so
good at making people appear to be
agents who are not agents what they call
in the political police business putting
a snitch jacket on an activist but
there's also ways to move publicly
activists around the country on campuses
have now been showing me um leaflets
that they're using when the fbi comes
recruiting
um
and it's like it's the cia off-campus
movement moving on to the fbi using my
book in a couple of campuses they've
actually done like a little resume
um
leaflet in the form of a resume in 19
1964 fbi tries to get king to kill
himself 1969 kill fred hampton and so on
you know the way a resume is organized
with the years down the side and the
activities
yes yes and and it's important it's
important because the fbi like the cia
depends on college recruitment in the
fbi's case especially out of law schools
in fact
and
because it's a great way as well of
educating people there are still the
cases of geronimo pratt leonard peltier
some other cointelpro victims former
black panthers that i now represent
known as the new york three hermann bell
albert washington and anthony bottom and
there's many other cases like that which
raise cointelpro issues you also in your
book you indicate what to do with people
who
seem to be fbi agents because they're
the provocateurs they're always wanting
to get people hurt or do something
violent or disrupt meetings so that you
can't
conduct the meeting act too crazy pick
fights it's one mode of being an
infiltrator it's another mode where
people are very quiet and cooperative
and do things on the sly but there's
this kind of disruptive uh provocateur
type agent and what what i counsel very
strongly
is that um
they those kind of people be dealt with
on the basis of their conduct
not on the basis of some claim or charge
that they're doing it because they're
agents they might not be agents
they might be emotionally right they
might be emotional exactly they might be
emotionally disturbed
if they're a real agent they'll say no
i'm not an agent he's the agent for
calling me the agent and the whole group
will go up and uproar and really the
issue is the conduct if a group has
clear ground rules about what
behavior in the group is tolerable for
the group to function
and those are clearly agreed to and a
person persists after being talked with
in behavior that is intolerable to the
group then the person can be excluded
for the conduct i think we have to be
very careful about loosely pointing the
finger at people that we think are
agents some people act different
sometimes people like ways we think are
strange we want our movements to be
broad and inclusive and and and be open
to very different kinds of people and
not to get overly suspicious i mean
paranoia one of the reasons they do
infiltration is to promote our paranoia
and the documents show that
they want us scared looking over our
shoulder who's the agent they want
people keep away from groups because of
that we want to counter paranoia well
how are groups coping with this and
you're traveling all around the country
dealing with activist groups are
activist groups on the move have they
been pretty much defeated by 10 years of
reagan bush or do you see a resurrection
of radical politicians i see a current
situation sorry i see a definite
resurgence and
it won't take exactly the same form in
the 60s did not look
just like the 30s and people some people
who were active in the 30s couldn't
recognize what was happening in the 60s
the culture was different the style was
different the issues were different
um the 90s may again
be different from the 60s in those ways
environmental issues are going to be
central and environmental groups are
being targeted
the aids movement aids coalition to
unleash power which is spread around the
country which is a very militant and
broad-based movement
against
what the government's failing to do
around aids and really campaigning for
national um health care i mean raising
all the health care issues that's a
major issue for the nineties the women's
movement is resurging um around the uh
efforts to smash abortion rights
um the central america movement
continues
the uh puerto rican independence
movement continues
there's there's movements
there we have less sense
of what's happening because it happens
locally in a kind of decentralized way
we no longer have much of our own media
to um to understand it and assimilate it
through you know in the in the sixties
one of the main targets was we had uh a
necro and under a network of underground
newspapers 400 underground radical
newspapers alternative newspapers austin
had a big one the red right they were
all over the country and they had their
own news service
the liberation news they were really a
major target of cointelpro
um they would do raids and and and
vandalism and break up offices and do
forge correspondence and set people
against each other and on and on and on
well thank you for being with us i wish
we had more time i wish we did too yes
we need to have our own studios and we
can just go on absolutely we need the
people's media as you're beginning it
but this is an extremely important book
to read the war at home by brian glick
now for more news stories from the
alternative press we begin with an
evaluation of the mass media coverage of
the gulf war
some people feel that the coverage has
been biased neglected or censored
something that appeared in the daily
text and in february
david lowry he's a managing editor at
the austin american statesman feels and
stately flatly states that coverage is
not adequate at all he claims the
pentagon has been controlling news
coverage by centering details of the
violent side of the war which is an
interesting thing to note because it's
almost been a very sterile war you don't
really seem to see the violence you see
the tanks you see the military coming up
with their thumbs up but you don't see
that the other side of war um
we also have fernando dovalina he's an
assistant managing editor of the houston
chronicle in agreement with david lowry
and he said that the military learned
its lesson from vietnam which um you
know that the press was claimed to be
not part of the team when we didn't
agree so the military learned to sort of
work around that
he says that the public believes the
media helped fuel opposition to the
vietnam war and the scariest part is
that most of the american public from
certain polls that are released again we
question these certain polls
from all polls agree with the government
that there should be censorship
and the villa says that the media has
actually done a poor job of explaining
what our job is which is investigative
which that side has been neglected
we hear a lot about saddam hussein as a
villain but we don't hear about was
there any possible reason slight or
remote that he was justified for
invading kuwait or that he had any
diplomatic recourse we don't even begin
to look at those possible ideas as if
they're no no of course they couldn't
exist which as a journalist is is
frightening that they aren't even
explored
with not seeing any of the bloodiness of
war what do children think it's it's big
bombs it's almost like some kind of sick
nintendo video game
we're not seeing the consequences of war
and therefore it's not as real for us
sam hennessy of fairness and accuracy in
the media based in new york said that
the war coverage was lacking from day
one in the crisis a couple of articles
in the austin chronicle talked about
this and they showed about uh comparing
the american censorship with the
censorship which
reporters had to deal with in iraq
itself during this period of time the
iraqis didn't censor anywhere as much as
the americans did
according to peter arnett and also a
british reporter
whom i heard interviewed on npr they
said well you have the iraqi sensors
there they're because every time there's
a news story coming out of iraq they
said clear by the rocky sensors he said
no they didn't they didn't censor
anything i had to say they had other
things to do what they did though was
limit my access to certain areas such as
battlefields or areas of a lot of damage
or places where there were government
military targets
however the americans censored quite
heavily and quite specifically a lot of
stories coming out of those areas for
instance one reporter said that after
the americans blew uh
the navy blew a an iraqi ship out of the
water and sunk it they
picked up the
sailors who were survivors
and the american
reporter was saying that these people
were taken prisoner and the american
censor wouldn't let him say that can't
say taken prisoner or can't say captured
so he changed it to
rescued
and so uh i mean that's how heavy-handed
and picky however this wasn't uh all the
way through some sensors american army
sensors were pretty laid back and
liberal others boy they x out and red
pencil at every other word frank that's
true that's when that the pilots came
back from the first mission initially
they they were reported as being um
jubilant and giddy but then that
subsequently they were it was slashed
and it was released that they were proud
upon returning from their first movie
hey what's this i heard about some of
them were shown skin flicks to get their
testosterone running high so they can go
kill civilians
well frank that uh that that's something
that that i heard as well that um
that they were shown that before going
out on missions to get the adrenaline
pumping but it was thought the navy
spokesperson felt that it was too
embarrassing to the military to have
that released
there was another interesting thing that
happened once again reported by the
austin chronicle
talking about the censorship these are
articles by carter mann
and it said that
any reporter who tried to work outside
the system or sneak around and find
something
unique found himself branded a renegade
or a you know or a
troublemaker or something like this and
the other reporters really would hammer
on
on these people who tried to really do
their job
they talked about two associated press
reporters who worked outside of the pool
and
went uh bypassed the checkpoints and
actually got some information some
unique information on the battle of
kafji
remember where the iraqis came down and
in saudi arabia and arabia and captured
that town for a while
well
the
when the editors around the country
began to castigate their own reporters
in the field about uh letting the
associated
press reporters get the scoop on them
well these reporters in the field
turned on the
associated press reporters calling
unilaterals that was the term they
called the anybody who tried to skirt
around the regulations of unilaterals
as a matter of fact and then the
military people threatened them with
arrest if they tried to do that again
so it was uh
such a strange thing you know wars are
part of history we have to report these
things people need to know
about them
but even with the reporters having these
nice cushy jobs where all they might
have to duck one so ever so often if a
scud missile came over but heavens they
had it pretty easy the
uh saudis for instance
during the battle of kofti they were
embarrassed about the invasion of their
territory
and they were supposed to provide a trip
for the reporters to go around and see
what happened there but you know what
they did
they instead of doing that they
said hey folks we're going to have a
camel auction and we thought you might
like to see it we have a weekly panel
option and the press well they signed up
in droves and as a result they didn't
get anywhere near kafki except these two
renegades these two
unilaterals
the latest or the march 25th edition of
the
of the spotlight
indicates that
apparently
the big western banks particularly the
american banks
had a great deal to do with the outbreak
of the war
and what happened was that iraq had an
enormous debt they were the third
largest uh debtor in the world of course
we know who's the first the old stars
and strikes we're number one that's
right
but they had gotten a lot of
loans from the arab
countries the oil-rich arab countries
and it was kind of thought you know the
arab countries the oil-rich arab
countries were using iraq to keep that
strong so that they could beat back iran
because the
iran the muslim fundamentalism
if it spread to these
gulf
kingdoms and fiefdoms and chiefdoms and
all like that
uh that could cause a lot of problems in
those countries so they were willingly
giving money to iraq so iraq could fight
iran
however
at the
on the advice of a chase manhattan
investment man
in
saudi arabia
they sold a lot of this debt to chase
manhattan and some other western banks
american banks particularly
some about nine billion dollars of this
debt
so instead of being a gentleman's
agreement that well we'll give will this
is a loan but you really won't have to
pay it back suddenly the western bankers
were wanting their money
so they started putting
a lot of
pressure on saddam hussein said hey boy
you better pay up or we're not going to
give you any foreign credits now
iraq needed an awful lot of money to
come in to finance their economy
so
it looked at this point like saddam
needed
more
money to pay off these western banks and
he had his problems with kuwait because
kuwait was keeping the price of oil down
and saddam wanted it up
and so this is one of the main reasons
he moved into
kuwait and as a result of this
were the banks hurt
they
money all these oil all the windfall
profits
that were being
brought up through the american oil
companies they went to the big banks who
hold who sit on the board of directors
of the oil companies and who hold the
main stocks
in the oil companies
also the wall street banks reap the
benefits of the frightened gulf emirates
who supposedly moved 38 billion dollars
from other banks into the american banks
and the city corp
got the most they got 600 billion
dollars of capital infusion from
saudi arabia
so the banks apparently
manipulated this whole thing to start
out with and they benefited tremendously
and it might even tie in with us
to prevent the american banking system
from failing which we've talked about
for so long all these things tie in
together
yeah it's remarkable
it's just remarkable uh you know the the
kuwaitis
had 120
billion dollars
uh in cash and investments around the
world so when the invasion came they all
just moved to london
and
took over the management of those funds
and now
now that the war is over and their
country has been devastated now they're
doling that out and who are they doling
it out to well let's see bechdel uh the
largest construction company in the
world it's based here in the united
states and
uh
the board of directors of which uh is
basically a list of uh cabinet members
over the past 20 years uh you know
weinberger and brown and all these
people and george another one is in
dresser industries and george bush
hasn't been involved in dresser
industries as well as bechtel
so they get to come in and reap all the
all the benefits of rebuilding the
country it's just a nice little enclosed
world
60 to 80 billion dollars in contracts
they're sitting there waiting to be
sucked up oh god while the
american
military and
government officials and people in
general are crying about how we kicked
the dom of saints but over there
you know it kind of reminds me as if
say there's a seventh grader who went up
and went down beat up a first grader he
and his buddies
and so the football coach or the the
high school
principal finds out about it and tells
his football coach to go down hey
take care of that seventh grader and so
the football coach gets some of his
buddies from other high schoo high
schools and they get a bunch of football
players and they go into the seventh
grade and they beat up on that
seventh graders but they also
unfortunately they kill half the kids in
the seventh grade while they're beating
up on the seventh grader and then they
go crowing around town about hey boy we
whap that seventh graders but us and all
these senior high school football
players that's what it reminds me of
that's just disgusting
the most advanced technological
countries in the world going have been
beating up on a on a third world country
with second grade second rate equipment
and that brings us to the end of this
alternative views
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media if you would like to have these
send a stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas 78713
you must send a self-addressed stamped
envelope
we also can provide you with information
on how to get some of the publications
of former cia officer john stockwell
we'd like to thank some of the people
and organizations that made our program
possible
the national lawyers guild provided us
with
speakers for not only this program but
some other programs for alternative
views
remember the magnificent book by brian
glick is entitled the war at home
we'd also like to thank our
crew
for these two
shoots which we had brian lynch was our
director set the lights did the audio
melissa crowley michael ferris karen
bynes and susan ginsberg
all were camera operators
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279
austin texas 787
13.
goodbye